democratic leaders in congress plan to
get president biden's domestic agenda
big a big test this week the president's
plans for infrastructure
voting rights and police reform are all
on the line
those initiatives face strong opposition
from republicans
and even some democrats are unhappy with
the latest debate on infrastructure
chris van cleeve is on capitol hill
chris where does that issue stand now
well good morning a lot of it is going
to depend on president biden's next move
we could hear as soon as today what the
president thinks about this bipartisan
infrastructure compromise
but already we're hearing from some
democrats who say they could be
a no vote after a bipartisan group of 21
senators back to compromise on
infrastructure
republicans are calling on president
biden to take the offer
president biden if you want an
infrastructure deal of a trillion
dollars
it's there for the taking you just need
to get involved and lead
the roughly one trillion dollar package
is about half the size of the
president's more than two trillion
dollar plan
it focuses largely on traditional
infrastructure projects
and has enough gop backing to pass the
senate if all democrats get on board
but some liberal senators may not
support it saying it does not do enough
to fight climate change or
income inequality the time is long
overdue that we address many of the long
neglected problems facing
the middle class and working class of
this country they had passed voter
suppression laws in florida
on voting rights the senate is poised to
vote on a bill tuesday
meant to push back against new
restrictive voter laws in several states
but democrats are still trying to get
all 50 of their members on board
west virginia's joe manchin the holdout
offered a compromise with items
republicans support like voter id
requirements and allowing state
officials to purge voter rolls
but republicans still oppose it likely
dooming the bill
it takes the election system in this
country and federalizes it so it's a
federal takeover of our election system
and police reform negotiations are
ongoing senator tim scott has said he
needed a deal by the end of the month or
he was
out senator graham told us last week he
thought a deal could be close of course
the clock is ticking the senate goes on
recess at the end of the week for two
weeks and
in july they're going to have to start
dealing with raising the debt ceiling
anthony chris thank you